I'm a dark night that fright out of your
sight and into the night I have a full
Batman poem hidden on the Internet
go find it it's real let's talk about
some Batman Beyond casting news this is
from we got this covered calm I wanted
to talk about this because I found that
a lot of the time when they report on
certain leaks or rumors they tend to be
right now they have news here of who WB
is reportedly eyeing for the role of
Terry McGinnis in Batman Beyond
live-action movie now I really want a
Batman Beyond movie I think would be
very cool you have like your standalone
Joker movie you got whatever that
universe is a Suicide Squad and Harley
Quinn and then you got your Batman that
Reeves movie yeah then you got something
way in the future that's more neo Gotham
Batman is really old and then you have
Terry McGinnis taking on the mantle of
Batman he's a completely different kind
of guy two guys aren't that familiar
with Terry McGinnis
he's like a rebellious snarky cocky
hard-headed young man and he eventually
takes on the Batman mantle really cares
for his family
so he's got a heart even though his
exterior is rather hard so they have
this casting report here actor who you
might have seen in the x-men franchise
and I got to tell you I'm not that
excited about it I don't know that is
one reportedly it is ready player ones
Tye Sheridan
who also played Cyclops who also
directed hell or high water Oh
who also directed win river didn't you
write Sicario he did he really did John
Weaver of course joking here at the real
rejects that is Taylor Sheridan far
better actors and I'd be a great Terry
McGinnis ty Sheridan I don't think he's
a bad actor at all I think he's a fine
actor he's just never done anything that
has really put it bluntly I've never
really been like really impressed I've
never really persuade me one way or like
they're sure like he's a much better
actor than me okay I don't really have
room to criticize him here but if we're
talking about casting for this movie
that could be a weird kind of Batman
film I would like more of a
controversial pick one that would upset
the fans but film lovers would know that
their acting chops are capable of
pulling it off similar to Michael Keaton
in the first
Batman movie witch's panic is rumoured
that they're trying to get him to return
for this film to play old man Bruce
Wayne which I think would be really cool
for him to reprise his role which is
something I think a lot of us have
wanted for a very long time I personally
would be more excited if they got Kevin
Conroy to be him Kevin Conroy proved he
can do a live action Bruce Wayne someone
more rough around the edges of the work
that he did in crisis on Infinite Earths
I thought he did a stellar job there so
I think it would be really cool if you
got over here
although movie fans would probably be a
lot more excited if they got Michael
Keaton in the role I'm not sure watch
leave your thoughts down below on who
you think would be more exciting for
Terry McGinnis ty Sheridan no one felt
to the actor but it's going to sound
certainly insulting I feel like it's a
rather bland pick he's very vanilla I'm
sure is a great human being like weirdly
am more drawn to actors who I think
could fit the role who I think people
might not fully agree with me on but
someone like Jo Keary who plays Steve on
stranger things who has that rebellious
attitude but also has a big heart or
someone who's really kind of strange but
kind of looks a little bit more like
Terry McGinnis I would say is Alex wolf
from the Jumanji franchise his work in
hereditary was excellent really showed
he's a capable actor who can bring a lot
of curb
Robbie toss to a role and I think that
would be an interesting departure for
him and to be able to showcase because
it could still be a cool transitional
rule someone who's a loner life
character with a rebellious attitude who
then takes on this Batman mantle and um
it's always fun to watch actors bulk up
for roles and stuff so those would be
kind of my weird picks and my picks
would be David Harbour and Finn Wolf's
hard for you know Batman and Terry
McGinnis respectively
maybe Edward Asner or something like
that in seriousness I think Caleb Landry
Jones would probably be like my pinky
has the wire enos that I associate with
Terry McGinnis ty Sheridan to me is
relatively fit but he is kind of like a
solid stocky build and I feel like Terry
McGinnis as I associate him is more a
longer character in general looks like
he can kind of get in and out of tight
spaces he doesn't look especially like
buff buff but he looks like he can take
care of himself so I guess I would think
of somebody a little more tall or slight
or something Alex wolf is a great choice
on the acting chops
I think Caleb Landry Jones just for me
would be able to handle the snark handle
the physique and also you know bring a
lot of acting
to the table well guys what do you think
about Thai shared I'm possibly being
this guy that's down below who do you
want to see play Terry McGinnis is your
personal pick subscribe click
notification bell to catch guys soon
you